[Applause]
oh thanks for coming amy thank you
congratulations first of all uh the show
is hilarious
thanks a lot really one of the funniest
shows on tv and uh you got to be happy
about that yeah
yeah that's great and you play your
you're the character we're seeing here
just in a nutshell explain to people who
haven't seen the show you play
jerry blank she's 47 and uh she was a
drug addict uh
prostitute and uh she decides at 47 to
go back to high school you know start
off where she you know left off
she's back in high school dealing with
teenage problems right likey literacy
sarah yeah well she's a it's a great
character it's a really funny show so we
know that that's going well what about
what about you your personal life how's
everything going is there you know
what's this
i'm in the middle of a heart-wrenching
relationship right now breakup it was
awful
you're breaking up yeah no he broke up
with me it was terrible but um and i was
just in the green room and he called and
he called me and broke up just before
uh just now that's terrible i can't
imagine what that would be like
yeah well i brought a clip so there you
can see
why did you kiss her do you love her
oh big show
[Applause]
i'm glad big show was there for you yeah
big show
he's understanding big shots yeah very
understanding now uh
you know you're you're you do a lot of
great characters what are the influences
i mean who influenced
who you are as a as a comedian um well
uh
a big influence was my third grade
teacher was locking me who gave me this
pin of a mouse and his eyes roll around
and cute yeah third grade still wearing
it anyway and uh
every day uh before class you'd make us
sing this song so i'll sing it she'd go
we're all together again we're here
we're here
we're all together again singing all
together again yes we're all together
again where
where
[Laughter]
did you imitate her way back then yeah
oh that must have she likes like tree
trunks
and her feet were the size of fudgicles
and they fit in there she's great
i hope she's still alive yeah i hope
she's watching this right now hearing
you say that she has
legs like tree trunks you
you do a character last time you were on
the show i made you do it
it's one of the more outrageous things
i've ever seen it's a character called
piglet
oh piglet piglet's kind of described
piglets oh she's just a sweet 16.
she's just a young troubled teenager
yeah we have scotch tape that's right i
brought it okay you need
you need scotch tape for this impression
yes i do and this is something you all
can do at home
okay you just take scotch tape and i do
a commercial for them
you just tape it up like that appreciate
this mother
appreciate this you can take your
stinking sack of hard luck
stick it up your blister it out
hello
she's a catch that one i knew piglet i
think at one point
yeah now what's impressed one of the
things that really impressed me about
you is that you're doing your own show
which has got it's a full-time
job you do it very well but you also on
the you work as a caterer still
i'm still selling cupcakes and cheese
balls i made 150
on valentine's day and uh with cupcakes
and then my my smokey cheese balls
the smoky cheese tell us about those
like the size of a softball and you can
roll it
in nuts oh and uh i put a little a1
sauce in to make it smacky
right it goes for 7.99 cool yeah well
actually that actually sounds like
something that i would like i'm sure you
i brought a clip let's see come on try
it
damn that's a smoky cheese ball
wow i really look like i was enjoying
that yeah
cool 7.99 i didn't even charge you
now you've been doing some work uh
you've been doing some work with peta is
that right the animal rights
group yes i did i swear to god when they
called me i had just unwrapped a
taxidermy
raccoon that i'd order i threw the mail
and i was just unwrapping it oh please
and they gave me this fur coat excuse me
[Laughter]
and they gave me this for coke that's so
nice of that people
of animals they're good people they are
good people i don't know what it stands
for or anything
[Laughter]
peta i don't know some kind of bread i'm
supposed to ski
now well we're all really happy for you
in the success of your show
and uh do you think you'll you'll come
back sometime in the future
oh i would love to come back as a matter
of fact i brought a clip
well thanks so much for coming back oh
thank you do you remember the last time
that you were here you showed all those
clips
including this clip right now
[Laughter]
so uh you and the big show are married
yes we're trying to have a baby right
now
oh really yeah well you'll be killed
during the birthing process that's what
i hear
very nicely done well folks strangers
with candies on mondays
at 10 o'clock p.m on comedy central you
got to watch that show you're missing
out if you're not seeing it amy sedaris
thank you very much
very funny we'll take a break we'll be
right back
you